Hey, what's going on? Is Bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
ah,
I'm just checking in on you. I'm
just checking in on you. Sorry,
I'm just checking in on you to
see now your week's going. Well,
a half hour checking in. How are
you doing? How are you doing? Okay.
Fed fucking tastic. You know, it's funny,
I'm always a day late and
a dollar short to shit,
so I fucking got a youtube page now.
Um, we're doing all this animation,
a fucking hiring people to do stuff.
Try to get this fucking
thing going to someday.
I won't even have to leave my house.
All I gotta do is just sit here and
ramble on about crazy shit as I slip into
fucking senility and I'll still
be able to eat my apple sauce.
I'll still be able to pay for some
fucking apple sauce. All right?
That is what that is what the
old age is all about. Okay.
You don't leave your house, but
checks is still coming in. Okay?
You got a cupboard full of fucking
apple sauce. Once you open them,
you put them in the fridge, you know,
even though it hurts your teeth. Oh right.
Cause you got to look at fucking nerve
involvement and all your fucking,
all your teeth. Right? You go back to
eating the same shit. You Steve as a baby.
It's just, it's like apple sauce is
Gerber food for fucking old people. Right?
So you got that. What else do you have?
You mixed a little Manet's in there.
Anything you don't have to fucking shoe.
Um,
so I'm getting a youtube page going
and then you know what these fucking
constant youtube do. Now,
if I can't even tell you,
they got this thing where they decide if
what the fuck happened on your thing is,
is a little too offensive.
Like they fucking decide and then
you don't get any of the ad money.
And I'm like, but the ads still
there. Who gets the money?
Youtube keeps it fucking unbelievable.
I'll tell you right fucking now the
number one commandment broken it.
I'm telling you, it's stealing.
There's more stealing that goes on,
on the legal side of business
for everybody's always
make. I'm fucking Scorsese.
He's always doing it.
You know,
if I fuck him forever or
whatever that fucking song is,
so I could go from rags to riches.
That's what the hell it is. Right?
All that good fellas. Shit, fuck you
pay me. Fuck you pay me all of that.
Like that doesn't exist
in the legal world. It's,
it's even fucking worst
and it's more overt.
That is just straight up fucking stealing.
So I don't know what I'm going
to do with the youtube page.
I'm actually thinking of what am I,
why don't we just move it to
my fucking website, right.
I'll reach out to fucking Miller Miller
high life. You want to fucking, uh,
if you want to fucking just be on all
my videos and I'll just do it on my page
and I could do say whatever the fuck I
want and not worry about somebody taking
my fucking retirement.
Apple sauce money.
It's not like I'm making
any fucking money anyways.
You've got to have like a billion hits,
I think to make $7. Well, you know,
you got to cure rate.
You'd be as they're talking to you here,
like a cash machine going off in
the fucking background, whatever.
Who gives a shit? All
right. You know what?
I am actually in a great mood
here I am in a great mood. And um,
despite that highway robbery,
youtube,
she call it your tube to
your fucking bullshit.
You're keeping all the
fucking money, your cons, um,
who gives a shit right at the end of the
fucking day? Well, obviously you do bill,
he wouldn't have brought it
up. I don't fucking mind. Just,
just fuck me over.
Why can't you just fuck me over?
Why can't you just come out and just say,
listen, we're going to fuck you over.
Why do you gotta to lie?
Why do you to sit there and
act like you're not going
to do it and then you turn
around and you do it. That's what upsets
me. It's not that you're doing it,
is it? You said you weren't going
to do it. All right. Anyways, uh,
bread.
Marshawn suspended for two games for
stab and Jake Dodgson in the balls.
So he got one game for each bulb, each
ball that he fucking stabbed them. And,
and uh, it makes sense. I
know a lot of people like,
well why didn't Sidney Crosby?
Cause what Sydney did don't you see is
he turned his fucking stick sideways and
he gave him a little tap, little tap
of the ball bag, like the same level,
that one, you know, the doctor
you go to get a physical,
he as you cross your legs and you know,
he hit you and you need goes up. Right.
Just like that.
He was just testing the guy's reflexes.
So he gets no suspension or a penalty,
you know,
plus he has those big pouty lips
and everybody feels bad for him.
That's the genius. Sidney Crosby, Sidney
Crosby has a look on his face, you know,
like right before you make your girlfriend
cry and then you're like, oh my God,
she's going to cry.
So you just abandon your argument.
Like that's what his face looks like.
So I think that's why he's able to,
that's why he's able to get away with
what he gets away with. Plus, you know,
he's a superstar and he makes everybody
a ton of money. So Brad Marshawn,
you know, you live by the sword, you die
by the sword. I remember branded press,
fucking stabbed him in the nuts,
uh,
when we will play in Vancouver
a couple of years ago.
And then what's funny is to listen to
Jack Edwards when he sees Marshawn,
he's such a fucking homer.
He's just sitting. They go, oh,
look at all that is Blake
Lee out of the rules.
That is a delicious video
for the boys in New York.
Hope you enjoy your day off.
You're talking about
definitely a suspension and uh,
and then march tion way, you
know, fucking just, I mean,
he uppercutted this dude's nuts.
His stick was not on the flat side.
Like he was giving it a backhander,
you know,
he did an upper cut with the stick
to the guys Taynton Ball area. And,
um, like, you know,
when your wife tells you to shovel the
driveway and you're already pissed at you,
you know how hard you throw those first
two fucking scoops of snow over your
shoulder. That's how hard he hit
this guy in the fucking nuts.
And I got to tell you, as a Bruins
fan, I thought I was like, oh my God,
he just fucked us over cause he
just got kicked out of the game.
I think it was still zero to zero
against the Tampa Bay lightning.
And we were waiting to, um, you know,
see if we were gonna make the playoffs.
I'm like, oh my God, he just got to give
right at the end of the first period.
I'm like, he's going to get kicked
out. That's gonna fucking, you know,
give Tampa of little jumping,
nailed their, their game.
They're going to win this fucking game.
He's going to be out for the rest of the
season. And, um, and then we're going to,
you know, I catastrophize in my
head, what if we fucking, you know,
don't make the playoffs
because of that play off.
But fortunately we ended up winning I
think four to one or four to nothing. And,
um, if we beat Ottawa
tonight, we can actually,
uh, you know, we at the
very least are going to be a
wildcard. But I mean I don't,
obviously I don't feel like playing
fucking the capital's right now.
They are looking like world beaters. But
um, eventually you will have to play in,
but it'd be nice to maybe have a
chance to win a playoff series.
We'll see how we do though. You
never know. Golf tenders can get,
they get hot at the right time of year.
There's no telling how far you could
go in the Stanley Cup playoffs.
Um,
I feel like for me,
I just feel that um,
that's actually become
part of my vocabulary now.
Cause every time Nia watches
those fucking reality shows,
people who just go for me or Tiki, I
just feel, and now I've done it so much,
now I'm doing it. So I am officially
bill Kardashians right now. All right.
I'm not thinking about transitioning.
I'm not going to die.
What's left of my fucking, I got him.
I got my head shape now, but my beard,
I'm not going to dry diet.
Fucking jet black, you know,
but like the Kardashians,
I did marry an African American,
so I feel like I'm halfway there.
I think I could actually say that I'm
one of their cousins. I don't know. Oh,
I see a Photoshop coming anyways
to get back to uh, to the hockey. Um, uh,
so yeah, so we're in the playoffs for
the first time in a three fucking years.
So it's great to be in there and hopefully
we'll be thought of what tonight.
And uh, I bet my Sean cost
himself a little bit of
fucking money there. You know,
I would think in his contract that he
gets a bonus if he gets 40 goals and the
man was sitting on 39,
we're going to play Ottawa tonight.
Forget about the rest of the game that
he could have played in Tampa playing
auto tonight.
And according to the puck off podcast
hosted by Joe Part Nick on the all things
comedy network, he said that a auto has
got a lot of injuries in their defense.
Who knows?
So I guess what you take away from all
of that is that if you're in the NHL,
if you're going to fucking
hit somebody ball bag,
you do it with the flat side of the stick.
All right? You get yourself, you know,
some college and injections. India
lips like a Kardashians. I don't know.
Maybe they did it then.
I Dunno. Um, you know,
so you look like you're about ready to
cry like Cindy Crosby and you will not
get suspended.
All right?
But I guess she heard Crosby other night
fucking slash somebody and almost took
the end of his fucking like the guys
into the guy's finger was hanging off.
You know, I'm going to go out
on a limb and say that guy,
he's going to have a, uh,
there's not really like any of the
goons anymore. These to have like that.
That's like players like Crosby.
Students just have like security,
like back in the day in
like the 80s, like the, the,
the fucking tough guys
back in the 80s where like
they did everything but just have like
blue blazers on an earpiece is standing
next to the goal scores. If
you went anywhere near them,
they fucking murder you.
And I'm,
I'm trying to think of who,
who the penguins have penguins
never really had a goon.
They had a bunch of fucking knee breakers.
They were really into like, well,
we're not going to fight you.
We're just going to end your career.
Blow out your fucking knee board.
You and that type of ship filthy,
filthy fucking franchise. But you know,
the penguin isn't dirty bird, isn't it?
Sort of the pigeon of the Antarctic,
isn't it?
Did you guys hear their buildings
on luxury condos down there?
Luxury condos in Antarctica, you
know, the people in Silicone Valley,
they don't know where
else to spend their money.
They already bought up San Francisco.
That's starting to come down here to
la and a for a summer place because San
Francisco is so fucking cold. Um, that
the next thing that they're going to do,
it can be down in Antarctica.
You can look it up.
It's true luxury condos in
Antarctica and a la to Antarctica.
They're going to have the first direct
flight in July. All of that is true.
I'm not making this up at all because
I have a half hour to a to fill up here
and I'm only 10 minutes in. I would
never do that to you guys. Um, all right,
let's talk about, oh, Billy
beefcake care. All right.
Fucking Dad Bod Magoo who,
uh,
after his European run last summer,
whereas up to a fucking 190 pounds.
And then I kind of started working out,
getting ready for my special.
I got down to like a buck
78 finished the special.
And are they really specials anymore now
that there's one coming out every week?
It was just sort of
bill talks for an hour.
I think the sense my
special came out in January.
There's been 97 other hour long specials.
I think there's been out one out
every day. Um, anyways, so I,
uh, I got down to a buck 78, 79 ish and,
uh, and then I was just like, all right,
now I'm waiting to become a dad. You know,
my wife was in the third trimester,
so I'm going to try meth,
so I'm going to fucking
blame her a little bit,
even though I don't always just
drink it too much of everything.
So I got up to like a backup
to like a buck 85 buck 86.
So now last week I got
myself down to 180 pounds.
This week I wanted to lose at least two
pounds. All right. The way in is tomorrow,
but uh, I'll just start
doing them on Thursday. So I
wanted to get down to one 78,
maybe one 77.
Got on the scale today.
One 77.6.
All right. So I am, um,
I got one day on a film coming up.
Oh, aren't you fancy, Bill? Yes, I am.
I got one day at a film. So
ultimately, you know, I need to be,
to not get too much shit on Twitter about
being a big booze headed fucking bald
headed red cunt. You know,
which always fucking happens.
All these fucking actress fucking bitch
Moan and complaining like the Internet
is only mean to them. I swear to God,
fucking self involves of lunatics,
right?
Um,
I got to get down to like my fight and
win choosy about a buck 72 on camera.
If I walk around a buck 75, you know, um,
if you just see me coming down the
street, I mean I look radiant. Okay.
You're going to look at me like Jesus.
Bill, are you expecting book at that?
Look on your face. I'm fucking with
you. But I got to get on camera.
I got to be down to a buck 72.
All right.
And every fucking actor knows what
fucking wait you gotta be at. So you know,
and you'll all get,
oh,
you just gauge it on social media feedback
cause you're just going to get a ton
of shit.
The second you go a little power dude,
you look like Vince Vaughn in the end of
the fucking, uh, the breakup. You know,
that was my favorite part of that
fucking move. I love that fucking movie.
I loved how Vince did the
fucking, he had the, uh,
not in a relationship fucking,
you know, out there crushing ass.
And then when he was in the relationship,
he had that extra 10 to 15, you know,
the Netflix, wait, let's
sit here and you know,
make some Mac and cheese and play footsie.
Um,
I don't want to ruin the end of the movie,
but, uh, that, that's one of the best,
you know, and that was a chick flick
to cause it was about a relationship.
And that's one of my favorite things
about it was it played out in a real way
right down to the, you know, when he's
not in a relationship, he's fucking,
you know, he said his
fighting weight, you know,
I'm trying to attract somebody to
fuck me again. Okay. You were a layup,
so I had my layup extra 15 on, right.
That's what I'm trying to lose right now.
Oh Billy, lay up. Wait, so I'm
down to one 77.6 so next week.
The official way in is on Friday, but
I'll do them on Thursday just to give a,
just add a little excitement in your
life because I'm so self involved and I
feel like you guys actually give a shit.
So do a with me lose two pounds
this week at least if not three.
So I want to be down to about a buck 74,
uh,
by Friday next week and then we shoot
the following week so I can actually be
down to one 73. You know, if I
puked behind a dumpster, you know,
take the old fucking, you know, you know
what route? I guess she can't even see.
You can't even say bulemia without
people freaking out unless you're like,
it's one of the worst of the others. You
can't even use it as a comedy reference.
Are you allowed to, are you
allowed to say, you know, use
that as a reference. Like,
I'll go, I'll go if I
have to, if I have to,
I will make myself fucking Yak for
fucking a day to get down to the buck.
72 to till liver,
my line and a half on this movie,
Bill Burr,
King of the line and a half.
If you've got a line and a half that
you need to fucking be delivered by a
tertiary character. Did I use that
word correctly? I am your fucking man.
I will show up on time in shape,
ready to fucking work.
I'll show up at my fighting weight
of one 72 I will deliver that line.
I'll even give you a look.
All right to give me like a,
a special and special appearance
by Bill Burr, the opening credits,
whatever the fuck that's called, I
will actually throw in. I'll give you,
I'll give you the rock,
you know,
with one of my invisible eyebrows
that you can't really see. Um, yeah.
So I'm going to get down to
that. I'm going to get down
to hopefully like a book,
whatever, 72 whatever. Look at me.
Sound like the fucking rain man.
But that's the only way to do it.
And then eventually I'd like to
get down to one, a buck 68. Okay.
And then not do what I always do
to be like, oh, I'm a buck 68,
you know,
who wants some fucking cookies?
Let's get a fucking 12 pack,
you know?
And then I slowly but surely
go right back up and, uh, I,
I have to make a lifestyle change.
I just feel like for me,
I'm going to be a lot happier if I cut
out gluten and I still don't know what
gluten is.
It's some sort of chemical
that's in wheat, I believe in.
Evidently it's not good for you, even
though wheat is, is from the earth,
but you know,
there are poisonous plants or is gluten
like some shit that's some fucking nerds
made for psychopaths that have food
companies that adds to the density or some
shit and somehow they make more money?
Is that what it is?
They're always looking to do that shit.
You know what I mean?
You can't fucking satisfying these
fucking lunatic, these fucking guys,
the men at the top of these corporations.
You know what they're like,
they're like a bunch of fucking Brunch,
you know what I mean?
Like don't matter what they
have then Emma fucking happy.
You know you got straight hair now you
want curly hair and now you want short
hair.
You know they ain't want to wear a crop
top that you want to fucking, you know,
have clam digger zone. I don't, I don't
know what the fuck are they should do it.
Could you just put on a fucking pair of
sweatpants and just sit down for five
fucking minutes?
Do you know how hard my wife would
be laughing at this shit right now?
Cause I'm the one who I fucking
but don't look like this is supposed to
be my relaxed energy right now and I'm
still talking too fast. Whenever I
listened back to my podcast and like, why?
Why do I talk so fast? I thought it
would, I thought I talked a lot slower.
I need to have like
cocktail party energy now.
Even a cocktail party. You got to yell,
you gotta Yell over people. Right?
Okay.
I Dunno. Cocktail party,
just call it what it is.
We're getting away from our kids to get
shit faced for a few hours. All right?
And somebody's going to try
to dominate the conversation.
Somebody is going to fucking bring up
politics. Someone's gonna get too drunk.
Then there's going to
be a fucking argument.
Then this got to be apologies afterwards.
Why doesn't everybody just pick a
fucking corner of the room? Okay.
Okay. Stare at the carpet and just,
just start drinking. Okay. That's it.
Why else are we here? Is it some swingers
party? We going to trade off here?
Like what? What is going
on? I don't, Maggie.
I don't give a shit about your worldview.
You don't hold public office.
You do not have access to top
secret documents in the Pentagon.
So at the end of the day,
what am I doing here on?
I really listening to like a nurse
trying to tell me how to fix a car.
Isn't that kind of the same thing?
Would you like to hear what I think
about fucking the Middle East course?
You wouldn't lot,
right then finish your fucking drink.
Um, anyways. Uh, what else is going on
this weekend? Oh, I'm going to be in,
I'm going to be in San Antonio,
but not one show too.
Two shows at the majestic theater.
Oh my God, it's so majestic.
They added a second show. I want to be
doing some morning radio tomorrow to hype.
That second show.
I'm doing that one show.
I'm doing two shows like Brad Marshawn.
Oh,
I'm not going to fucking
stab you in one ball.
I'm stabbing it to not going
to get suspended for one game.
You're suspended for it.
I'm going to do one show for every game.
Brad Marshawn was suspended.
Okay.
Was unfairly targeted cause he in in a,
in a moment of emotion,
he used the shoveling,
the snow fucking technique and he did
not have the Sidney Crosby pouty lips for
when he went to the board in New York.
I think that's what's Crosby does.
You know, he just, he doesn't
even have to go to New York.
They just fucking put him on Skype
and he just sits there like, hi guys.
I'm Shari. You know, it's
just having a bad period.
Oh, isn't it amazing how much I could
talk without even knowing what the fuck I
ain't know what I'm talking
about here. Um, Hey,
do you guys want to know how to
change a shitty diaper properly?
Are there any parents out there? Here's
one to grow on. Here's one of my,
here's a tip for you. All
right. What happens is,
is when you have a little base,
yeah.
Say the word saint a Goddamn fucking
hard. You're going to be okay. Uh,
if you have a baby,
um,
and you're breastfeeding it as
opposed to giving it formula,
I'm staying away from that shit.
I just,
I don't like that fucking name
formula at that fucking name alone.
I'm not giving my baby formula.
You know,
I was just picture like when those
Frankenstein movies with the graduated
cylinder cylinder and the dry out dry
ice smoke coming out of the top of it.
So anyway, so they bay, yeah, they got a
liquid diet going on. So when you know,
when the fucking backdoor comes off
the hinges, as they say, uh, you know,
this is the deal. The second
you hear the fucking, you know,
the rumblings and the grumblings,
what you gotta do is you got to get your
kid not horizontal if you got to have
them upright, all right?
Now this is the problem.
When you take them down to the changing
table, when you lay him back down again,
okay? And you're taken off the one Z,
you got to elevate them a little bit.
You know, as they say, shit runs downhill,
okay? So what you want to do is you
want to use gravity as a favor. This,
it's a two person job. If you're
going to save that fucking onesy,
all right?
Which you got to do is you have to have
the baby fucking standing up on the
changing table,
all right?
The other person on does the onesy lifts
the ones z up over the fucking diaper,
and then you take the diaper off,
like you taking the transmission out of
a car that's up on a lift, all right?
Then he use gravity.
Everything drops down.
I'm trying to be as not graphic
as humanly possible, okay? Then,
you know, then you begin the fucking, uh,
the restoration
because I'm telling you right now,
if you're home alone, all right,
and you lay that kid down den,
what? Shit runs downhill now?
What's on the ones?
You got to take it off.
You've got to go over the kids fucking
head and now you got shit on the fucking,
I'm sorry. And this is what it is. I
don't want to put shit on the kid's head.
Yeah,
I tell you, it's a rough one. You know,
so fortunately that fucking happens is
somebody else around. Uh, I'm sorry,
I didn't mean to get that graphic,
but you know,
people who are parents are telling you,
just one person holds it up.
The undo the ones that you dropped the
diaper out, like a fucking trans mission,
you know, do a little cleanup.
Then you fucking set the kid down.
Then you finish the fucking clean
up. Bam. A new diaper. Actually,
you don't even do that.
You usually,
we just bring her into the fucking shower
and start all over again with a brand
new squeaky clean fucking kid.
And there you go.
There's a little parenthesis, my first
per unsolicited parental advice. Okay.
I just felt like for me,
I just felt like it needed to be sad.
Is anybody watching that
reality show? Black ink? Uh,
my wife watches it all the time.
There is a woman on there that makes
my temper look like a fucking summer
breeze.
Good Lord.
Does she lose her fucking shit?
It's like she's possessed.
Um,
I actually just literally
have to walk out the door,
but I know I keep forgetting this show.
I started the watch.
I watched the first three episodes and
I absolutely fucking loved it and I
tweeted about it. It was a cartoon from
Japan, I guess they're called anime,
which I did know that,
but I didn't realize it was
such a divisive thing to
say that you liked to show
that was anime. I feel like it is
animate like the emo of fucking cartoons.
Like I tweeted that,
I liked this show called one punch man.
Okay.
All right. And the fucking
responses that I got, I got, dude,
are you fucking drunk? Oh my
God. You're in the animate.
And then other people just like this.
I just like to show I've watched enough
for the same type of shit and I was
scrolling through and I was like,
what the fuck is this show?
And I looked and it had five
stars, four and a half, five stars,
which is why I really hope Netflix
doesn't go to thumbs up, thumbs down,
like I said,
because it's so fucking
okay.
You know, stubbing your toe, thumbs
down, Adolf Hitler, thumbs down.
I mean the thumbs down is this,
there's a big gap between Hitler and you,
you know, sub when you're
fucking tope. Um, anyway,
so I put this thing on and
what I loved about the show,
mmm.
Aside from the fact that I really saw it,
it was funny that you actually kind of
got like a sense of what young people,
okay.
Feel like in Japan as far as their view
of going into the corporate world was
very similar to the empty feeling.
Unless you're a fucking
sociopath over here,
I find like a very like common thread to
that and to basically give the overall
thing the superhero in it. He's not a
soup. He doesn't want to be a superhero.
All right?
Any fucking trained really hard cause
he wanted to be the strongest guy in the
world. And in his training, he lost
all his hair, which is hilarious.
And he's really self conscious about it.
But he ended up developing
like this punch.
And no matter what monster he runs into,
he doesn't give a shit
whether they kill him.
He's just completely devoid of
any like passion or emotion.
Like what happens to you when you get
shoved into a fucking cubicle and a,
and he's got this one punch and he just
fucking kid punched so hard that no
matter how fucking bad ass the monster is,
he gives him one,
somebody said they should've called
the show, the right they have Fred.
He gives him the fucking
fire in the fucking and,
and end the face is Eddie
Murphy says it the face, um,
and their fucking head explodes.
And the monsters that he fights,
you also get more of an insight
into where people's heads are at.
Okay.
Uh, in Japan and it was like, you know,
one of the monsters you fought with,
some giant virus sent here by
the Earth to get rid of the war,
all the humans because of
what we'd done to the planet.
So there was environmental thing.
Then my favorite one was
this guy who was crab mad.
He was half like up top and it was all
a crab. And then the bottom he was,
he was half a guide and
he was in the bottom half.
He's in his bare feet and tidy whities
okay.
And the guy's like, oh, I ate so much
crab me that I became a fucking crab.
And to me he represented the
upper 1% corporate guys, you know,
on some power lunch, just eating all the
fucking Sushi and just take, take, take,
take, take, nothing spiritual about them.
So he gave him the old right there, Fred.
And then he fought this fucking lie and
she had command of all the mosquitoes
and she'd sit the mosquitoes
on everybody's suck all
the blood out of you and
all your fucking energy.
And then it would make her stronger.
And to me it's like all this is a gold
digging, blood sucking whore. Right.
And then once she got it to do it to
all the animals and everybody there,
she didn't need the mosquitoes anymore.
She told all the mosquitoes
to go fuck themselves.
And I'm like slash this is also somebody
who becomes successful and forgets
where they come from and they look
at everybody where they used to be.
It's like a bunch of fucking pee on a
bunch of little insignificant little
mosquitoes. Right? It's
a lot of levels to it.
Or you can just get fucking high and
watch this bald headed dude fucking punch
half a crab in the head and want
you to explode. I enjoyed it.
Okay.
Right.
Let's do a little fucking advertising
here before I wrap up and I talk about
Moto GP and the Fon Chinese
Grand Prix and my glutes.
All right. Loot crate
everybody. Uh, gimme the loot.
Are you on a quest or an EP for epic
gear, housewares and collectibles. Oh,
do you have a one punch man t shirt?
This is finally going to fucking
make sense to me. Loot crate. Has it.
The best surprise, you know,
is coming. Loot crate operas,
an epic range of pop culture
items for less than $20 a month.
If you're more of a fanatical
fashionista than eight,
then try loot where monthly wearables
and accessories with coke classics and
your favorite franchises.
Do you want to get fancy,
get a bigger box with an even bigger
loop with loot crate dx one to keke out
your pet.
Try loop pets.
Offer expires April 19th at
9:00 PM Pacific for April.
Join us as we salute one of our
favorite mystery solvers with items from
strangers, things, Batman,
the x files and Marvel's Jessica Jones
do get some one man punch shit in there.
One lucky subscriber.
We're also when a mega crate including
signed copies of Jessica Jones alias
volumes one through four Oh Jessica
Jones alias volumes one through four.
I have not, I might as well be
reading a different language.
I have no idea what any of this
shit is other than stranger things.
And I know Batman and I used to
know this chick named Jessica. Um,
you have until the 19th
at 9:00 PM Pacific.
You just said this to subscribe
and receive that month's crate,
and when the cutoff happens,
that's it. It's over.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
burr and enter my code burpee.
You rr to save $3 off any new
subscription today. All right, here we go.
Here we go. How many of these fucking
things I got to read? All right,
lift everybody.
L Y l to the motherfucking YFT.
You know about Lyft, right? Well,
it's the APP that gets you
a ride in minutes on demand.
24 seven for less than the cost of a cab.
Please include all of the falling
points during your read. Well,
if it takes too long, I'm not. If
you tried Lyft, you know what I mean?
With Lyft, you got, you just
download the APP, ProQuest to driver,
and they show up in three and a half
minutes on average. That's really fast.
You know,
unless there's a fucking guy chasing
you with an ax and that's probably takes
forever.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted
through their 10 point safety standard,
including criminal and DMV
background checks. You know,
you'll get around quickly and safely
other than that other one. Ah,
that rhymes with mover Lyft drive
driver's are rated after every ride,
so the only the best stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting
into a filthy car with some creepy dude.
With Lyft, you can tip in the APP, which
obviously leads to happier drivers.
I mean nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a
perfect five star rating from the passage
yet it's just a better all around
experience. Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest
riding ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing and the
rated one I'm talking about quality over
quantity. Thanks to lift. You got
an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to bum a ride and you
never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting
rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to
get around and you know what?
I don't blame them.
Evidently right now Lyft is offering
our listeners a special offer deal.
Get three rides up to $10 each.
There's a up to $30 a fucking dollar
value when you enter Promo Code Bell Barf.
People don't wanna listen to his fucking
long. That's Promo Code Bill Burr.
Enter Promo Code Bill burr
cut to the fucking chase.
All right, he looks everybody. So one
punch. A fucking reference. Sorry.
Helix Helix. I Dunno, you're unique.
You're a special little snowflake.
Take a bath and reconnect with yourself.
You don't walk like anyone else.
Talk block anyone out or
sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
I Dunno.
Cause there's an average height of a
human being because it truly customized
mattress will cost you five to 10,000
bucks. Who? I didn't know that until now.
Go to hell.
Helix sleep.com answer a few simple
questions and they'll run a three d
biomechanical model of your body through
their proprietary algorithms they've
developed with the help of the world's
leading arrogant omics and biomechanics
experts.
The results,
there's a fucking robot that looks like
you walking around blowing Donald Trump
and eventually they get rid of you.
But in the meantime,
you're sleeping on the most comfortable
mattress you've ever slept on.
He likes sleep.
Helix customers report a 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
How do you tell honey tea?
I guess when you wake up in the morning,
how much better you feel and for cups,
customers, you know what happens is,
is when you're sleeping, right?
Are you going to do the survey?
That robot that they made,
a you comes in and fucking churchy off
while you sleep and you wake up like,
oh my God, I'm so fucking relaxed. And
then once you give the approval rating,
that robot leaves. That's it. That's
how they do it. And for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door
in about a week and shipping is free,
100% free. That's why everyone
from Gq magazines, Forbes,
are all talking about helix sleep. Helux
uh, you have 100 nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free Rovs and
give you 100% refund. No questions asked.
Go to hell. And sleep.com/burr and
get $50 off your order. That's helix,
sleep.com/burr helic sleep.com/burr.
All right. Lastly, but not leastly. All
this is great. I'm trying to lose weight.
I have to do this. Blue Apron, everybody.
Not all ingredients are created equal,
fresh, high quality ingredients.
Make a real difference. So it's important
to know where your food comes from.
Talk about your personal, personally. I
went to listen to the corporate boardroom.
[inaudible] portrait,
personal experience with Demille.
You'll cocktail grade your 12,
all how our treasured heartfelt
or cooking or [inaudible].
Um, this is my experience. Every
time I read it, I want to try it.
I've never done it. They sent me a
gift card. I'd use the gift card,
but I don't like going on the
Internet trying to figure out shit.
I put it on my wife's desk.
I'm hoping at some point she's going to
come across it and that she will get it.
And at some point some keenwah will
show up wrapped in a blue apron.
That's my experience.
Additional points featured as
desired feature as design. Oh,
I like this. I get it. I get it.
I get choices here for less
than $10 per person per meal.
Blue Apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with pre portioned ingredients to
make delicious home cooked meals.
Choose from a variety of new recipes each
week or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you or recipes are
not repeated within a year,
so you'll never get bored.
Customize your fucking recipes each
week based on your preferences.
Blue Apron has several delivery options,
so you can choose the
one that fits your needs.
Maybe you can have your fucking helix
robots show up and give you a Goddamn cous
cous and there's no weekly commitment.
So you get deliveries
whenever you want them.
Each meal comes with step by step you.
They'll show you how to cook it.
You can have it done in 40 minutes
or less to fucking healthy.
You're going to get your apps.
People will be able to see your abs.
Everybody has abs. If you didn't have
abs, he couldn't sit up in bed. All right,
check out the two to watch your
robot just running out the door.
Did I just dream that?
Check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron.com/blog
you will love how good it feels and
tastes to create incredible home
cooked meals with blue apron.
So do not wait unless you want to.
That's blue apron.com/burr blue apron,
blue apron.
A better way to cook.
That's the only way to deliver that line.
That's why they had the comedy. You have
to pause. That's old school advertising.
You can't say blue apron. A better way
to cook. You gotta be like Blue Apron.
A better way to cook. Okay,
bill on this take on this tape.
Did you discover the word
Blue Apron as boy? Like, Ooh,
I didn't know that was
there. Yeah, I can do that.
Can I give you three different
reads? Yeah, that would be
great. Okay, here we go.
Blue Apron.
A better way to cook
blue apron.
A better way to cook.
Okay.
Blue Apron.
Okay,
a better way to cook. How was that?
That was great, Bill. We got it.
Okay. We'll see you next week. All
right. Thank you. Yeah, hang on a second.
[inaudible] this is Susan
[inaudible]. Quali um, anyways,
let me get back to,
sorry,
I was just giving you guys a little
behind the scenes on voiceovers.
Did you like that? Did you feel
like you were there? All right,
let me wrap this up.
Uh,
this weekend I'm for the first time I
think I'm going to watch an entire moto GP
race. I believe it's in Argentina.
It's somewhere down south. Oh, who?
Yay.
No further south than that.
[inaudible] action. Who the fuck
I'm getting texts from right now?
Oh my God, I don't remember that
person a minute. All right. Anyways,
Moto GP and then the Chinese Grand Prix.
Um,
this is,
this is a very great weekend before the,
the NFL and NBA playoffs start.
If you would like to watch
some alternative sports
sports that are not as big as
the big four here in the United States
of American. Who, who's kidding,
who are country matters the most?
Therefore our sports matter the most.
All right. People know our
star athletes around the world.
Nobody knows people in the premier league.
You know,
the only reason why we knew that one
fled Beckam guys cause they made a movie
about it and he was fucking one
of the spice girls. All right?
If he wasn't fucking some chicken, a
girl band, nobody knew who that guy was.
Okay. We mattered the
most. All right, let's,
let's try to have a little
more empathy as Americans here.
Let's watch some fucking great sports
from around the world. Moto GP,
if you want to watch a bunch of lunatics
driving about 180 miles an hour right
next to each other,
taking turns fucking maniacs.
And he also the technology and that
sport, do you know like those suits? Now?
I don't know how they figure it out,
but they figure out that the riders
fallen off the bike and before he hits the
pavement, pavement ideally
like the, the, the,
the suit that they wear has like an
airbag that just fucking immediately
inflates and protects all the vitals
in theory. You know, obviously,
I dunno if you fucking slam into a wall.
I don't know what happens then. But, um,
and then the Chinese Grand Prix,
the second race,
the second of 20 races,
there's only 20 racists.
It's very easy to watch this and continue
to watch all the other sports that you
love. You can tape it, you
can just fucking watch it.
And uh, the Ferrari's one,
the first one was Sebastian Vettel I
believe. And uh, you know, I'm sorry.
I'm sure fucking
the fuck's his name.
Lewis Hamilton is not
happy about that shit. Um,
and I was actually going to go to that
tt race this year and the Isle of Man and
ended up fucking falling apart.
So, um, I got to go next year.
I got to go next year before they
make it fucking safe. I have to go.
And if you've never seen that race,
more people have died than
years that they've had it. Um,
the balls these people have,
it's like fucking real
life mad max type shit,
except it's still running water and
all that stuff. Um, anyways. All right,
let me talk about my glutes. Give me a,
this is something I realized
as I'm rehabbing all these
injuries and my body is
that through years of sitting
on planes and sitting on cars,
like I fucking,
I have like no glute muscles whatsoever.
Like beyond the usual fucking white guy,
no ass type of shit.
It's just like my fucking thighs
do all the work. So I've been,
I've been doing these squats where kind
of push them from your heels and when
I'm coming down and I'm trying to have
most of my weight on my squat on my squad,
so my heels with my torso
like straight up and down,
not leaning forward to counterbalance
the lack of glute muscle that I have,
I start to come down
into a seating position.
I have to do it like over
my workout bench. Cause if I
just tried to go, you know,
mainly depending on my glutes,
I will literally fall down like
the first 30 degrees I'm okay.
And then I just fall down to the bench.
So I got to get that going.
Um, just what I've been doing,
I just went on and I looked
up the top 10 glued things.
So I'll do an alternative leg lunges.
I got an exercise ball up against the
wall that I put on my back and I go all
the way down to a deep squat pushing
up through my heels. Then I do the one,
um,
well you lay on your back,
your feet are planted on the ground and
then you, you lift your hips up, you know,
with the glutes sat way. It's
almost like you're, you're,
you're sort of thrusting up as
if you were fucking somebody,
you know what I mean?
But way up,
like they were lighter than air and
you could actually possibly do that.
So I do those and then I do the
alternative fucking leg lunches.
That's what I'm doing so far.
So, um, hopefully, I dunno,
I had no idea my body was so god
damn fucked up. But evidently it is.
But I am one 77.6. I'm very excited
about that. And, uh, do what we,
everybody come on the summer's coming up,
lose a couple pounds a week with me.
Cut out the chips, the cookies,
just fucking drink waters.
Sign up for that blue apron shit.
You know,
have a robot come and delivered it to
your house. Be done eating by five,
six o'clock at night.
And even if you get home later,
just I always try to go like fucking at
least 12 hours without eating when I'm
trying to lose weight
for like the last day.
Like if I finish eating around seven,
I'm not going to have breakfast
to like fucking nine. Um,
if you do have a day job,
just have like, I don't know,
have like a lighter breakfast
or something like that.
I don't know what the
fuck I'm talking about.
All I can tell you is what works for
me. All right, that's the podcast. Uh,
have a great weekend. Your cons, check
out some of the outline. You know,
what else was on this weekend?
The fucking man,
I'm the one golf tournament that
I really try to watch every year.
It starts today. So just, um, you know,
if you don't want to watch the last couple
of fucking games of hockey, you know,
I know baseball's going in that type
of stuff, but, uh, I don't know.
This racing stuff's pretty fucking
God. Damn cool. All right. That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll see on Monday.
Nice.
Marcy is completely addicted to skating
now and he wants to get better at it.
And, um, so we're fucking
then, uh, Edmonton,
the next morning we got to drive
down to Calgary and Florence.
He's going like this gotta be a place here
to skate. So we find out they have, uh,
they have a
skating rink at the mall
and I only use it a mall.
It's one of the most giant
malls in North America. America,
West Edmonton Mall rivaling. Uh, what's
that one in Minnesota? Mall of America.
All of America. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So, which I've been to that one too,
so we go to that one,
but walking through there with a fucking
skates to middle aged guys walking
through this thing with
fucking skates and we walk in,
there's like this giant pirate
ship. I mean like, yeah,
you could say all the fucking ocean
with this fucking thing. Yeah.
It was a flicker of official
and I look on the other side,
it was really deep water and they took
all this time to make it look like there
was a ship or like Jesus Christ.
I mean like you could fucking
yell was monstrous man.
Like Shaq could drown in this water if he
didn't. That's how fucking deep it was.
Huge. And then we look on the other
side and I'm like, Paul, I'm like,
is that a fucking sea lion?
They had sea lines at this thing and
they're like thrown at fishing shit.
Fishing.
It was catching or was,
it wasn't like people just walking
by throwing shit from the food court.
It was a trainer thrown it.
And um,
so we're just walking through the mall,
walking through the mall. Endless fucking,
well, they had a water park there. It
was insane. I didn't look at any stores.
I was too distracted by
the shit in the middle.
And then we finally get all
the way to the ice palace.
They called the Ice Palace and we got all
excited and we're the only people were
skates just walking through,
holding a fucking dumb skates and we
get all the way to the other side versus
all excited. Like, dude, I'm telling you,
I'm gonna get better at this. You wait,
I was getting, I was ready this
summer. He's already talking shit.
They were calling it right now.
I'm going to be fucking skate backwards.
You're going to be like, what
the fuck happened? Versie right.
And then we show up and uh,
there's a big judo tournament where the
ice rink is and they'd fucking put all
this floor flooring all over.
And maybe this isn't the rink.
Maybe this, this dude, it says
ice palace fall. This is it.
They covered it up. This is it.
I got upset though at the moment.
I remember that girl, man,
that really bothered me.
We were walking through the food
court and you know, we had a gyro.
Great Gyro and yeah, yeah. At Great Gyro
at this place called Jimmy the Greek,
the one complaint. And you agreed a little
too much white sauce in it was pasty.
Yeah. Cause it wasn't. It wasn't,
yeah, it was a little pace.
He's just got one scoop.
He went to one scoop lesson,
a little hot sauce in it would
have been hide it. You got excited?
It would have been epic. Yeah, we got
excited. So then I said to bill, you know,
I like a little dessert after I eat.
You know, I like a little candy bar.
I like a little, you know,
so I love sugar, new tank.
So I go bill Mann, it was the frozen
yogurt place. I go, yeah, pink barriers.
Some said go, let's go get
frozen yogurt. See? All right,
so we're walking by hate the pictures.
So two middle aged men was skates
and you keep saying I'm Middle Age,
you are Middle Age,
some 30 I just turned 35 35 times two is
70 most guys fucking drop when I call,
I call it like I call middle late. Yeah,
right. What, what would you call it? No,
I guess you're right. I guess,
you know, I always just,
when I thought of it as a kid, I always
felt, you know, it was now, I don't know,
I just remember, dude, I, it's, I
dunno, we'll just say 40 forties but I,
you know, bored. He's 40 people.
Do people live long, man, dude,
I'm fucking be 46 46 times two
is 92 you're going to really,
I can't really sit there and say,
I'm middle aged.
Tell you the way I'm eating
and smoking, you know? No.
So, so we walked through and
we're were like, where does that,
where was that a frozen yogurt place?
Let's go to that frozen yogurt place.
So we too, we see two young
women walk by and we figure, Hey,
I looked at him and I'm like,
these, these, these ladies,
they're going to know where they're
going to know where a pink barriers.
So we walk up and you go first. You say
to the friend, you go, hey, you got,
you guys know her. Oh, that good. They're
good looking too, by the way. Yeah. Good,
good looking girls. And you
go up first. You Go, hey,
you guys know where the
frozen yogurt places and like
she did like a double take.
Like she did a double take, so fucking
rude. Right? And she just was like, what?
And then I looked at the other one
and I go, yeah, like a pink berry.
And she kinda just like gives us
shake off. Like how would I know?
Like why are you and she fucking did.
This is what she did.
She did the classic pretty girl,
you're clearly just asking me this
because you want to talk to me thing.
And I'm like, no bitch, I want some
fucking yogurt. Okay, I want fucking,
I want to fucking treat. You know, I just
had lunch and, and it really bothered me,
dude. And we were walking around and I
wanted to find her. I wanted to find,
walk past this again. They did the
loop on the fight. I didn't know that,
but I said to bill and we got to
the car, I go, I wanted to find her,
cause I would have just went up to and go,
you know something,
I found it and you're a mean jerk. And
then you go, why would you do that?
You're a mean jerk. That's terrible.
What am I going to call her a cunt? Well,
don't call her anything if you're
going to go with me and jerk. I mean,
you know I hate that you're a
girl mentality. That pretty good.
Say you're mean or you're a jerk if
you want to stay clean. But if you go,
you're a mean jerk. No, you're not.
You're not. You're not pretty inside.
You're not pretty inside. It doesn't give
a fuck. She's the hot girl at the mall.
Paul put yourself in her fucking pumps.
All right?
With two fucking locker.
Jackass is standing there with ice skates
when there's a judo tournament down
the way, asking if they know
where the ice cream store is.
Big looked at us the way they were
suppose to I, you know what, dude?
I like a sweetheart.
I don't care how you,
I would love to hear them tell the story
and then they come and then it's just
creepy. Guy Comes up like, yeah, but
that's the way they're going to hear it.
Paul. Paul, you ever watch those
fucking prison shows? What he wants?
Like the scared straight? No,
not those ones where they,
they talk about the worst prisons in the
country and that type of ship. Oh yeah.
I've seen a couple of,
and you just sit there watching it going,
how the fuck would I go in there and
not get raped? What would my game plan?
He gets scared watching
it in your bedroom, right?
Women have to walk out of
the house worried about that.
That somebody is going to, you
know, do just imagine if, if, uh,
did I had a winter hat on with a puffy
ball on top of it, holding ice skates,
asking for yogurt. If anything, she
probably thought I was fucking gay.
You don't look gay, Paul. I
know, but you're not, you're not,
you're beards to terrorist that you need
to get a little more metro and not to
do that. We was, we had
sweatpants on. Do we want a mess?
Everybody in the fucking girl?
Yeah. That's what you look my beard.
My beard actually fucking says everybody
on the fucking ground. No, but dude,
I don't like the pretty girl who can't
be approached with a question because Oh,
this guy's hitting on
me. It's, it's awful.
And you know something that especially
the blonde one who went like shook her
head like what?
She's going to be a nightmare.
She's a fucking nightmare for some future
guy. I'm telling you, she's a nightmare.
She's already selfish.
It's over.
What if she just knows what
she wants and we're not at,
Oh this is the thing dude.
You actually aloud like how
old do you think they were?
I would probably 2122 yeah.
You let a 2122 year old.
I met a girl at my age, not even a
one way. She shake it all that way.
Let her ruin like to do with
driving down to Calgary.
She ruined like got the rocky mountains
on the right hand side of the car and
you're just still calling. You're
calling her a cunt the whole way down.
It bothered the shit out of me. It was
like, why are you, why would you ask me?
How would I know? Dude? You realize how
funny that is that they did that to us?
Like what? Like yeah, they really made us
feel like shit. That's fucking hilarious.
If you look at it and father and the
whole time is cause you wanted to get
frozen yogurt dude.
How funny would it be if we chased him
down and I want to go frozen yogurt with
sugar free gummy bears on it. It was
still all natural, no organic gummy.
Because how great would it be if we chased
him down and I just walked up to her
and I go, you know something,
you hurt my feelings.
I just fucking broke down.
You hurt my feelings.
I just want a yogurt. Oh by
the way, people listen in here.
This is last week. You know,
you know, just trying to kill,
just trying to make jokes
to not go out of your mind.
Being on tour this fucking long is we
were doing the Dangerfield. Everything.
I'll tell you, I've got a friend
of mine loves yogurt, you know,
so we were doing that and once
that went away, that got old.
Somewhere along the line
you started doing it.
You started saying really sentimental
shit to me and then pretending like you
were crying and then that just became
like the running joke and then you started
laughing and then you were just like,
you got to do that on stage,
do that crime things. So now we'll just
go up and like if we'll be like, hey man,
I'm tired, but dude, you
know what? Hang on, hang on.
What you on the road has been great.
You're the only one I
could have done it with.
And then bill would come and tag it.
That's the best thing.
Bill would come and tag and
I would just be like, oh,
I was hoping you were going to say that.
It's been,
it's been fucking wonderful for my anger.
I'm going to try to do that when I get
home and telic 10 like I'm crying, man.
It's fucking hilarious.
So two stories.
We go in to eat and we have this
Filipino waiter, right? By the way,
I like to play the Games where I sort of
hell. Where were you? Was that Edmonton?
Was that Calgary? That was
Edmonton. Yeah, it was Edmonson.
So I like to do this thing where
sometimes I like to fuck with people,
so I'll just get on a phone
and I'll be like, Bill,
go along with it and we'll be in
an elevator and I'll go, what? No,
that's horse shit. Like bill, just
look what happens. So like I said,
like he had a parole officer called
and he said, and bill goes, oh,
they worked it up. And then
instantly Burgos yeah, but
what about that videotape?
I go, Nah, Nah. They said it's
insubmissible and like, am I the Guy?
If there's just a stranger, they're
right. Sometimes I break out laughing.
So bill calls it, he gets a
little emotional guy. So we,
we turned this crying thing, we do it
like this has been great, right? We turn,
we turn that into doing it in public.
So we have this Filipino waiter, right?
And the old guy guy was great. He was
talking to us and at the end I just go,
he goes, here's your bill. And
I go, I just want to say so.
And I kept the dead straight face. And
again, you've been a great way to her man.
And I put my hand on his
fucking arm and I, you know,
you bring him a waters and bill just
looks at and goes, he gets a little,
he gets a little emotional, you know
what I mean? I know, but it's big.
It means a lot. I didn't
know what the guy had. No,
cause he was so fucking polite and
he was actually from the Philippines.
So he's jumped right in.
Perfectly good friend.
He gets a little emotional
like no, but bill, he'd bring
the waters. I'll do, well,
he was freaked out though.
Oh that's the new game on the road.
You have the best one. I've got to say,
the best one was at the airport yesterday.
We got to the airport yesterday and
bill starts busting my balls about my
laundry and he goes, Versie fucking
16 days and you're carrying, you know,
dirty socks and underwear. And I go,
dude, I go, I bought new ones. You know,
the dirty ones are tied up tight in a,
in a plastic bag and bill just goes,
just took your emotions. And
Dude, I fucking could not walk.
I couldn't walk and I had to
stop pulling my fucking bag.
I'd checked cause we were laughing so
hard. And it works though. It makes it,
it makes, it's fucking great. It's
driving a tour manager nuts. Oh yeah.
That's the one thing.
Well because women don't want to see
a guy getting emotional like that.
It's just, well no, cause once
somebody cries it's over. Yeah.
Like when I go out afterwards and I'm
taking pictures with people and stuff,
I always come back. I was just
saying, I got to tell you, you know,
I've seen a lot of people do that,
you know, doing the picture thing,
but you gotta be one of the best
wives. She's going, would
you stop doing that?
Our wives are going to go nuts cause
you know the first thing I want,
I see stays and you see your wife, we're
just going to go. It's been so long. I'm,
it's just so much. No, you got it.
You got to set it up with talking.
Like you just got to
start off normal white.
You're going to say something
really sentimental to them,
so they're almost crying and then you cry,
which ruins their crying.
And I swear to God, you get slugged in the
shoulder, which is all you really want.
Oh Shit. 20 minutes. Then
I'll tell you Paul, you know,
time really flies with you on the porch.
It's been so fun.
This is probably only funny to us,
but I don't give a shit.
Try it with your friends stuff. Fuck
that. If people, the game is called,
he gets emotional and
just walk into a bar.
Just have one of your friends started
hitting on a woman and then the other
friends got to go along.
Yep.
And then just starts welling up and
then the other guy goes on. Sorry.
He just gets emotional and you just got
to let the other person to deal with it.
Dude, you want it to fucking airport where
you walked up to that lady at the con
though? The little fucking I sell gum,
whatever the hell it is. Excuse me.
Do you have the, you have the, what are
the biggest night I broke out? Yeah.
I'll go. Hey ma'am, I need to, what
are the biggest condoms you got there?
What's the biggest size condoms you have?
I turned around and walked away and you
turned around and walked away and I'm
just staring at her and I'm biting my
tongue as hard as I can to not laugh.
And then I just burst out laughing at her.
She said what?
And then when you went to repeat it,
you to try to point to it and I lost it.
You lost it and had to walk away. Paul,
we're punch drunk out here. You don't.
One of my favorite things in this business
was opie from the opiate Anthony show
was he had this thing that he would do
when guys would start crying when they
would play audio. Yeah. Oh my God. It
was fucking, his timing was perfect.
Every time someone would be
talking like retiring from a sport,
like when Mike Schmidt
retired, which is, you know,
it's very difficult to watch
these guys, you know, you know,
he just was ending is like 38 years ago
a little boy began a journey to play the
wonderful game of baseball. And the
pope, he would always go, oh boy,
what am I favorite? And it always,
oh boy. It always meant, oh,
nobody wants to see a man just
completely do you know what it is?
I can watch a guy cry if
something terrible is happening.
Just don't try to talk while you're
crying. Yeah. That's the thing.
The talking and then bursting out into
Christ. Let your shoulders go. Yeah,
let me shut fucking crying.
But don't fall for the love of God a man.
He's a man. Needs to cry in private.
Yeah, you do that in the shower it,
he's doing it in the shower. Like
when my son was born, everyone's like,
did you cry yet? And I'm like,
no, what are you talking about?
And then when my son was born,
it all hit me later and I went home to
go get stuff for my wife in the hospital
and I sat on the couch
and I didn't like weep.
Gotcha.
I didn't weep when I got emotional.
But like just fixing you,
sitting on the couch by yourself and just,
you just go,
that's stupid.
It's just completely unexpected. You
use your thankful for your podcast. Oh,
that's unexplored.
The effective,
unacceptable dude on a completely
the talk into it, right? Yeah.
The talk into it. That's, that's what the
funny thing about crying is, you know,
it's like, you know, you
always do this to me. You know,
you always do this to me
and I'm trying my best
fucking over whenever my friends die,
I've had so many of fuck it died.
I just cry in the shower. Yes. What I do,
I asked the girl, we asked a girl, right,
cause you don't feel like
you crying because there's
all that water on your face
anyway. No. We asked the girl, we go,
what would you do if you're a dude
started crying. Like if it wasn't,
if nobody died,
if a dude and you were just [inaudible]
he just had a bad day and he just had a
bad day and you got into it and he broke
down and cried. She goes, yeah, no. Over,
over, over. Get the fuck away from me.
You know what's funny? There's some women,
they think that they want
to see that part of you.
They don't get what that is to them
is that's their total conquest.
Like you know when you bang a
girl in the ass and you just like,
yeah I got this shit.
I'm fucking with you.
Their version. I was just like
Jesus pill. No fuck we do.
Their version of that is is if they can
get you to be so vulnerable around them
that you cry and then
it's one of those things,
it's almost like when the crowd screams
out of joke, they already heard,
they think they want to hear it again
and then you tell it's like ah yeah it
wasn't as good. Now it's the same thing.
Is that, yeah. You said something,
you said something about
like if a burglar comes in,
if you cry in front of a woman,
all her mind is like,
what if the burglar comes down at
this fucking guy? Yeah, no it's over.
You can't cry. You Strip a
woman a security if you cry
in front of her. I think,
I don't think I've cried if I think my
wife saw me. That's what it is. Yeah.
You Strip her of her security. Cause now
she's like, well I got this fucking, yeah,
this foreign crisis, this baby sleeping
next to you every night, you know? Yeah,
it's, it's over. You know
what I mean? I know you just,
you might as well just have a
pullover sweater on, you know,
walking around and then she mocks you.
What are you going to cry Bitch,
you so me?
Yeah,
it's fucking over dude.
You can't have that if you have a car.
Have you ever cried alone listening
to a song or like get, not cried,
but have you ever been like,
oh no,
I completely broken down and I've told
three cars just weeping uncontrollably.
I bought. Yeah, totally cry. No, no,
I've definitely teared up.
Listen, as an, as an artist,
at some point you're going to have
to go to those emotions you need.
You need to be a, you need to meet to
with your instrument. No, I have, I,
what was the ones like I
had this weird thing where
I stopped crying at some point.
I Dunno,
when I stopped crying and got mad more
when, when I got hurt on my brother,
beat the shit out of me. Um, you
know, most of the crying I'd be,
it's just like at the end of it.
But I wasn't, but I wasn't crying.
I didn't cry
one time.
My brother is bigger than me. My little
brother's biggest thing. Right. Big Toe.
Like, and I remember he, I said, I said,
if you fucking take my clothes again,
if you take my clothes that he did it
every day he would go into my room,
we take my delta would take my clothes
and I'd come home and he gets in a boy
band and I need to go, I need to go out,
right. And I go, mom, if he does it again,
I'm fucking hitting him. If my mom
be like, oh, you know, he and he,
and one time I need really needed a shirt
and I'm fucking throwing shit through
the house.
And he gets out of his friend's car and
he starts walking up and he's got it on
and I fucking snapped.
And my grandmother was there.
And I jumped on him and I started punching
him and he stood up and he just goes,
well, you made your older brother
cried on my younger brother. Oh,
he's bigger than me.
But he didn't know what to do.
He got so upset that he just got,
and he looked around, he just,
he was so angry that something
needed to come out. And he just goes,
what did you feel bad? And you start
laughing. Oh, I kinda just walked away.
And you know, we laughed about it
afterwards, but to now, now he's a,
he's a fuck a big kid. But you
know, my mom had the opposite.
I got a little brother mind.
He's an animal, you know. No,
my mom said she went to a,
she went to a funeral once and everybody
was there and everybody was crying and
she was overwhelmed with emotion that
they had to fucking drag her out.
She said she had them. Uh, one of the
most embarrassing things happen to her.
What she said,
she uncontrollably laughed because they
said that that can happen sometimes.
So she's sitting there, she's, she's
sitting there and everybody's crying.
And like she went up and she could not
stop laughing and like she and I said,
why? And she was like, Paul,
I just don't know. She goes,
I could not stop laughing and I had to
walk me out and like as she just is your
mom?
Yeah.
She said because the emotions or some
bugs that they said that that could happen
sometimes where it just, you just
like, she didn't know what to do.
So instead of just breaking down,
she went the other way and just couldn't,
couldn't, yeah. Controller. Yeah.
Not like humans like will protect you
and a really like that's what they don't
get sometimes when comics make fucking
horrific jokes about some bad event.
Make good jokes. Yeah. It's about
a horrific event. So they go,
that's so fucking mean. It's a
defense mechanism. It's, my mom isn't,
my mom was a sweetheart who felt bad
and her emotions just went the other way
and she goes, Paul, I felt so bad.
I couldn't control myself should
I couldn't control myself.
I hate to say this because somebody
lost somebody, but there was,
if there was video of that. Oh
my God. Yeah. Oh, I'm sorry.
I was saying, so I stumbled
around, I don't know, 10 or 11.
I didn't cry for years. Years and
years and years. And I didn't,
I didn't cry until a friend
of mine killed himself.
And even then I was sad and
it's just, Oh, I went, uh,
I was in the bathroom once
again. Yeah. And it was in there.
And I remember I started to cry and then
I started thinking like, wow, I'm crying.
I haven't cried in a long time.
And then I stopped because I get out of
it cause I stopped thinking about the
Duke killed himself. Wow. Yeah. I went 10
years without a cry and then I had one.
What was it? Over Yogurt? Gummy bears?
No. Uh, I think, yeah, it might've been,
it might've been one of my son was born,
you know, it might've been on my
second one. That's acceptable.
I guess it's acceptable back in the day.
Just stood out in the waiting room.
Right.
I had a great time in Vegas other than
when I went down to the pool because I go
down to the pool, I'm down there
to me, it's fucking j lie had,
who's been killing it
in front of me and uh,
the lovely Niyyah and our cousins
and were hanged. Any cousin, I mean,
and we're hanging out down the pool and
they're doing the usual shit, you know,
if you're a red head and
he'd go down to the pool,
like you're just asking for people to all,
you know,
look how white you are. You
know, like, I had never noticed.
It's like I'm fucking around myself.
I've been around myself since the 60s,
the late sixties.
I know how white I am and if
I ever forget how white I am,
there's always somebody
there to remind me.
Okay,
sorry. I don't know if you've noticed
your skin tone. What am I meditating?
Floating up out of my body. All right,
so these people are with doe. Come on,
come on in the poor and like,
I don't want to go in the pool.
I don't want to go on the fucking
pool. You know, they're like, why? No,
why don't you want to go in the pool?
You know why? Because the fucking,
okay,
look at, look at these people. Look at
them, look at them. And you're getting,
you're getting you, you know,
would you take a bath with all,
with any one of the
people that you see here,
these fucking just masses of human beings.
There's not enough chlorine in a fucking
pool to kill whatever the fuck they're
dragging in the pool. You know, it was
like, I finally end up going to the pool.
Then everybody made fun of how white
my fucking alabaster chest was,
a da that I had to stay in
the shade of the fucking,
the lifeguard's chair,
you know,
you know, I had a show to
do, I'm being a professional,
I can't come out stage later,
half in the bag looking like, oh,
lot stuff right now.
I've got to do my little song and
dance later on that night. So anyway,
so I ended up getting in the fucking
pool against my, what I wanted to do,
you know?
Okay.
And then I get out of the pool.
Uh, first of all, for my age,
I am an absolutely
phenomenal top shelf shape.
Alright,
I got to tell you the fucking,
just the deaf fuck the humanity
that I saw poolside in Las Vegas,
the fucking humanity.
Okay.
Keyword manatee.
Not this gap step on a Jim Gaffigan.
I just realized he used to use that
reference and I'm pretty sure he used it.
I can't remember how the fuck he used it,
but if he used it to
describe a fat pale torso,
not really pale border, whatever the
fucking Shit I saw the side of the,
he was dead on that.
Oh my God.
Is there anything worse than seeing
a tattoo come of age? You know
Jesus Christ. If you get
a tattoo, you better.
You better just make the mental decision
that you're going to pay 90 x for the
rest of your fucking life.
Cause when you don't do it,
I saw this guy down at the pool.
All right.
He had like not only the worst
tattoos you've ever seen in your life,
like the worst placement,
you know what I mean?
Like you get one like on the side
of your arm up by your shoulder,
that looks good, right on
the bicep. That looks good.
You know Joe,
somebody got gets one right over there.
Voicebox like I don't give a fuck
what you have surrounding that.
That leads into that part of the,
of the of the work or the piece,
whatever they call it looks fucking
horrible. Leg Tattoos, horrific,
horrific.
So this fucking jerk off.
He has basically the exact sort of like
tribal thing that the rock has except he
doesn't look tribal. He looks
like an accountant, you know,
and he doesn't work out.
So just imagine if the
rock was his pasty as I was
and it never worked down in his life.
But has that same tattoo
that starts at the elbow,
goes up the arm over the shoulder
and covers one whole peck.
But the way this guy had it done was
it didn't cover his whole packet,
came swinging in and went right above his,
his man nipple.
So now all of the,
all of that is like colored in.
So because of the pace genus of his torso,
your eye is just drawn
to his right nipple.
Is he standing in the fucking pool?
My neck was sore from shaking
my head at people. It was,
it was absolutely fucking
horrific, right? So, so anyways,
um, I go back up to the, uh, I go back
up to the hotel room, right? You know,
gotta make sure that I'm all ship shape
for my God damn show and I put on the
news and what are they end
up doing a story about?
They start doing a story
about the amount of, uh,
fecal matter found in public pools
right after I just got out
of a God damn pool. You know?
And I know people always think, oh,
stay away from where the kids are.
Stay away from the Kiddie Pool.
Right? Stay away from that.
They always blame the fucking kids will,
ah,
you know something after seeing
what I saw a poolside, you know,
there weren't a lot of kids in there,
but I guarantee you somebody's got a cola.
I know this is fucking disgusting.
But people you've,
you're basically bathing,
you know what's even more fucked
up is Vegas is just like, you know,
people fly in all over the world.
You taking a fucking aids bath,
you know, with a shot of fucking, uh,
what the hell is that shit that came out,
but it killed people so fast
that it just burned out.
Everybody just ran into the woods.
The fuck was that shit called.
Okay.
Ah, Christ. I can't remember a bola.
That's it with a shot of a bola.
Okay.
Oh, whatever. Food poisoning. I don't
know what it is. A salmon, Ellis shower,
whatever the fuck you want to call it.
I'm done with public pools.
The only pool that I will
ever swim in again is my pool.
If I ever get one or the pool of some
hot chick that I want to fucking bank,
cause I have knee permission,
that's the only way it's going to go down.
Other than that, you know, I'll
just go, I'll just go take a bath.
That way I'm out of the sun. You know,
we'll take a couple of vitamin E pills,
whatever the fuck it is. You get
from the sun other than skin cancer,
I'm done with it.
You know what America needs to implement
after years and years of calling the
French people smelly.
You know?
That's Kinda like the thing when we went
over to France and saved their ass for
the second time last century. Oh wait, did
we do it once? We did it one time, right?
I can't fucking remember. So anyways,
we've always made fun of the French filed.
They smell, they smell. If you ever
watched a bugs bunny growing up, man,
you saw pepe Le Pew. If you noticed
he had a French accent, you know,
that's the kind of shit you couldn't
get away with today because of political
correctness. I guess they were basically
saying that you know that they stuck.
But I'll tell you one thing that the
French have when it comes to hygiene over
America. All right? Is the day. All right?
I can guarantee you if I ever go
swimming in a public pool again,
it's going to be at Fred's Ellis
is a bunch of Americans. I know. I've
been over to England. I never saw it,
but day over there,
you know,
but day is basically a car
wash for your asshole Ed. Uh,
you know,
it leaves you feeling refreshed,
puts a fucking smile on your face,
and evidently had France.
She's so fucking happy.
You forget to put on deodorant,
but I'll tell you right now, you can jump
in that pool. I bet they're not dead,
but they're not talking
about that shit over there,
right.
[inaudible].